This man you see on the screen, Recep Tayyip
Erdoğan, has been lord and master of Turkish
politics for the last 20 years. And now, to the
chagrin of virtually the entire Western bloc,
he has won at the polls again.
After surviving an obscure and bizarre
coup d'état, ramming through the Constitution and
implementing a bizarre economic policy that has
hit the country hard and wrecked the value of
the Lira, Turks are still betting on Erdoğan.
Under his leadership, Turkey has gone from
being a tolerant Islamic democracy and an
example of moderation to becoming an
increasingly uncomfortable partner for
both the European Union and NATO.
In fact, many consider that we are
on the verge of a new autocracy right at the
gates of Europe. For others, we are witnessing
Turkey's definitive break with the West.
Be that as it may, we are talking about
a candidate who has been seen handing
out wads of money at the doors of his
polling station on election day itself. You
don’t believe me? Well, see for yourselves.
But how did we get here and what does it
all mean? How did this Turkish neo-sultan
come into being? What is he after? Why did
he still manage to win the latest election?
Well..., we are going to answer all these
questions, but first, let's get an overview
of the situation.
Listen up.
The Ottoman Empire participated in
World War One along with Germany,
the Austro-Hungarian Empire and Bulgaria, in what
would be the last great action of this Empire,
at least under that same denomination.
In 1918 they were on the losing side,
so the victorious Allies were able to force
the then Sultan Mehmet the Sixth to sign the
Treaty of Sèvres . This treaty confirmed the
surrender of the Ottoman Empire and meant the
division of its territories outside Turkey.
It also provided for international control
of the city of Istanbul and the
Bosphorus and Dardanelles straits,
the creation of a large new independent
Armenian nation in eastern Anatolia, and
a buffer zone for the Kurds, who would be free to
choose independence after a period of autonomy.
However, this treaty was never ratified
by the Ottoman government due to Turkish
resistance led by Mustafa Kemal Ataturk, who
led the so-called Turkish War of Independence.
As a result of this war, the Treaty of Sèvres
was replaced by the Treaty of Lausanne in 1923,
which established the modern borders of the
Republic of Turkey and annulled many of the
provisions of the Treaty of Sèvres.
Later, the Second World War was already
a clear sign of what would become, from then
on, the double face of Turkish foreign policy.
You see, while the country signed a protection
agreement with France and the United Kingdom in
1939, the successes of the German blitzkriegled
Ankara to also sign a friendship treaty with
the Third Reich around 1941. The result? The
Turkish armed forces ended up being equipped
with both Allied and Axis technology.
But yes, in 1945, the Turks definitely
went over to the Allies. It was
not a particularly loyal position,
but the advent of the Cold War meant that all
this back and forth was forgotten overnight.
Competition with the Soviets prompted the
White House to step up to the plate and
sign a comprehensive security treaty with
Turkey, which has resulted in the delivery
of large-scale military aid since 1947.
And so, this is how the special relationship
between Washington and Ankara, and by
extension Turkey's relationship with
the entire Western world, came about. Thus,
the Turkish government signed its integration
with the West, joining the Council of Europe
in 1949, NATO in 1952, and the OECD in 1961.
However, Turkey was a country full of tensions:
externally, the deployment of US Jupiter nuclear
missiles on its territory, aimed directly at the
Soviet Union, put the country at the epicenter
of political debate throughout the Cold War.
On the other hand, internally, many politicians,
little by little, were trying to implement
a much more religious model for the country.
This was only stopped by the pressure of the
armed forces. For decades, the Turkish army
was something of a shield against the
growing Islamization of the country.
Although even this “mechanism” did not
always work in the most desirable way.
We are talking about two coups d'état,
one in 1960 and the other in 1980.
And that is not all. For decades, the country was
also immersed in a great tug of war between State
planning and market capitalism. Essentially,
between the end of World War Two and the 1980s,
planning policies and control of the economy
predominated. So did protectionism to supposedly
support domestic industries. It was only
from the 1980s onwards that the country
turned to the open market and capitalism.
And, VisualPolitik viewers, let there be no
doubt about it, Turkey's geographical position
as a nexus, a point of union between Asia,
Europe and the Middle East, was absolutely
crucial to this whole process. For this reason,
Western institutions tried to integrate
Turkey more and more. For a time,
it even seemed reasonably close to
joining the European Union itself.
Well, that was basically the country where
Recep Tayyip Erdoğan grew up and evolved,
a country halfway between East and West,
between secularization and laicization,
between capitalism and economic planning.
And so it was until the coming to power of
Erdoğan himself, the man who has practically
re-founded the country during the first two
decades of the 21st century.
Listen up.
(SOCCER, ISLAM AND MILITARY PRESSURES)
In May 1971, the Turkish armed forces
issued an ultimatum to the conservative
government of Süleyman Demirel and,
in general, to all political parties. The
military demanded that the politicians
contain the growing religious extremism that
was bringing chaos to the republican order.
This situation worsened after the onset of
a severe economic crisis, caused in large
part by strong trade protectionism.
The fact is that this crisis resulted
in high levels of unemployment – over
20% – and out-of-control inflation:
for example, while annual inflation was 15.4%
in 1972, by 1980 it was already over 94%.
Well, at that time, the government ordered the
illegalization of several parties for being
against secularization, that is to say, against
the model of a non-denominational State. Among
these banned formations was the National Order
Party (MNP) in which Erdoğan was a militant.
However, the following year, the leader
of this party, Necmettin Erbakan,
registered another similar grouping under
the name of the National Salvation Party
(MSP). Remember this name because it will be
key in the future of the still young Recep.
VisualPolitik viewers, the turbulent
1970s finally ended with a coup d'état
in 1980. That year the military junta
ed by General Kenan Evren ceased democratic
institutions, extended martial law, banned
all political parties and imprisoned and
tried tens of thousands of political activists.
During this time, with politics firmly shut down,
Erdogan explored other fields. For example, he
tried his luck as a semi-professional footballer
and managed to earn a university
degree in business administration.
The fact is that in 1983, under the cover of
the military's new permissive legislation, the
National Salvation Party was refounded into the
Welfare Party and under Erbakan's command, Erdoğan
once again jumped back into political life.
His big break would come in 1984. That year a
democratically elected government returned
to power. And just then, Erdoğan began to
gain political influence in the opposition.
He was appointed coordinator of the Welfare
Party in Istanbul province. His name,
little by little, began to be popular:
he represented the only Islamist force with
influence in the country's urban districts.
And so, in 1994, with 25.2% of
the vote, Erdoğan became the new
mayor of Istanbul. Keep in mind that
this was an absolutely key moment.
An Islamist party had taken control of the
main city in all of Turkey. The question
the country was asking itself was: What
would this government look like? Would the
Islamists put an end to secularism? Could
they end up provoking a new coup d'état?
Well... The truth is that Erdoğan knew how to
play his cards. It was the perfect occasion
to show that his Islamist party
could be a force of majorities.
And, as we say around here, no sooner said than
done. To the surprise of many, this mayor gave
preference to management over religion.
For example, he promoted a plan of public
works and new technologies to solve the
problems that existed in the water service,
in the congested road network and
in the waste system. Infrastructure
and public works were clearly his hallmark
and his springboard to national politics.
Suddenly, the Welfare Party seemed to have
put aside its Islamist agenda to become the
standard bearer of modernization
in the cities... And guess what?
In 1995 this evolution allowed them
to become the most voted force at the
national level in the general elections...However,
they were unable to form a government.
The military opposed them head-on,
and asked the other two major political parties,
the Motherland Party and the True Path Party,
to reach a government pact and veto the
Islamists. Moderate or not, the military
did not want to see them represented even in
the slightest in running national politics.
However, this pact lasted barely a year,
and on 28 June 1996, Necmettin Erbakan,
the founder of the country's only major
Islamist political force, succeeded in
becoming prime minister. And no, don't think
he followed Erdogan's path of moderation.
Erbakan wanted to push forward a much more
Islamist agenda. Among his main points was
closer ties with countries like Libya and Iran.
Something that was too much for the military,
which forced him to resign in 1997.
Shortly thereafter, the Constitutional
Court itself outlawed the Welfare Party for
carrying out "activities contrary to the
secularism of the State”.
And that wasn’t all.
The legal authorities also convicted Erdoğan
himself for inciting religious hatred.
Specifically, he was accused of having used the
following verses of the poet and
nationalist ideologue, Ziya Gökalp,
as a proclamation at a political rally.
Take note because he doesn’t mince words,
it was a clear manifestation of intentions:
("The mosques are our barracks, the domes our
helmets, the minarets our bayonets
and the believers our soldiers").
Erdoğan was dismissed from the mayor's office and
sentenced to ten months in prison. Wait a minute,
convicted for reciting some verses? Well, we have
already told you that the religious question was
a very sensitive topic within the country.
The thing is that we could all imagine that
after being impeached and imprisoned, Erdoğan's
political career would have come to an end. But
you can see that it did not. The question
is, what did he do to re-launch himself,
likewise, to re-establish his name, attain
power and gain such large majorities?
Well... We are going to take
a look at that right now.
(RECEP TAYYIP 2.0)
When Erdoğan regained his freedom, he was
completely banned from political life. There
was no possibility of becoming a candidate or
to form a political party. The question was,
did he really have to take on a clearly
Islamist role or should he shelve this
matter to try to return to the political arena?
Well... VisualPolitik viewers. It soon became
clear to him. He had to seize any opportunity
that came his way. His top priority had to be
to re-establish his public position.
After all, his role as master manager
in Istanbul was still in the popular memory.
And so, in 2001, when the ban on his political
activities was lifted, Erdoğan founded
the Justice and Development Party,
his political spearhead. It was a machine
that arrived at the best possible moment:
at the beginning of the 21st century Turkey was a
country in crisis where news like this reigned:
(25 February 2001: Turkey in turmoil. Faced with
a financial crisis, which has seen the stockmarket
plummet and interest rates soar, Turkey has
been forced to abandon efforts to maintain the
value of its currency, the lira – The Economist)
Average annual inflation was hovering around 60%,
the unemployment rate was rising sharply
and the value of the Lira had plummeted.
It was the big opportunity that our
protagonist was looking for. It was
his moment. The religious agenda was not
a priority, he had to present himself as
an efficient manager, recalling his more
pragmatic time as mayor of Istanbul. That
would give him social support in a
difficult economic period and, also,
it would calm the military's misgivings.
The result? Well... Take a look.
The elections were so fragmented that with
only 34.28% of the votes, Erdoğan's party won
an overwhelming absolute majority. His promises
of moderation and rapprochement with the European
Union earned him the approval of the military. No
one would stand in his way... And he would keep
his word. His Islamist agenda was shelved.
He also pushed through a reform package that
accelerated the privatization
of state-owned enterprises and
lowered trade and financial barriers. As
a result, foreign investment skyrocketed
and Turkey experienced an economic boom.
As we often say, there are times when a
picture is worth a thousand words. Well,
this is one of those cases. Take a look.
After Erdoğan came to power in March
2003 foreign investment soared,
the measures implemented brought inflation
back to single digits and the national economy
was going from strength to strength. It was
what came to be called the Turkish miracle.
And so little by little this political
leader assumed more and more power. To
the point that he became strong enough to
put his Islamist agenda back on the table.
We have told you about this in several videos
that we’ll link for you in the description.
After all, who was going to oppose him?
He had an overwhelming social majority,
was responsible for the so-called Turkish
miracle and had gradually co-opted managers
from all State institutions, including
the army... Although not the entire army.
Listen up.
(A LEOPARD DOESN’T CHANGE ITS SPOTS)
The change of political tone that Erdoğan
staged in order to come to power was somewhat
instrumental, it did not change his deepest
political convictions: Islamism and a very
authoritarian view of politics.
For example, in 2013, a group of
environmentalists demonstrated against the
demolition of a park in the city of Istanbul.
Although it was not a large-scale anti-government
protest, the unconscionable repression outraged
Turkish society and the entire opposition, who
used the occasion to promote huge protests.
The protests took place between May and June of
the same year, and ended with dozens of people
injured, numerous journalists arrested, and strong
threats against the media. And not only that,
during this period, Erdoğan's government tried
different kinds of ways to censor the internet.
For example, it restricted the use of Twitter:
(26 June 2014: Internet censorship in Turkey.
Since the Taksim Square protests began in the
summer of 2013, the Turkish government has been
stepping up violence to crack down on them. A
new law allows it to shut down blogs and Twitter
accounts that are inconvenient to it. – DW)
Likewise, Erdoğan gradually redesigned the
institutions to his liking and since
2010 prosecutors close to his party
began a campaign of arrests and interrogations
against senior officers of the armed forces.
And so, on 15 July 2016, an attempted coup
took place. For many it was the sign of the
military's weariness, for others a self-coup
organized by Erdoğan himself to clean house.
Whatever the case, the coup that resulted in
194 dead and more than 1,100 wounded failed and
this political leader took total control. Let's
just say that the coup gave him the possibility
to overhaul the army from top to bottom.
Already without the counterweight of the army,
in 2017 Erdoğan promoted a constitutional
reform that gave the ruler the power to
dissolve parliament and even appoint
half of the Constitutional Court.
From that moment on, all indicators
of freedom have fallen in the country,
the persecution of opponents has become
frequent and the media has been gradually
tamed, if not controlled in most cases.
To make matters worse, from that moment on,
foreign investment began to plummet and Erdoğan
brought to the table an economic policy based
on Islamic dogmas, For instance, against interest
rates, which has destroyed the value of the lira.
In a way, Turkey has become more and more like
Russia... A country with which, despite being
a NATO member, it maintains practically full
relations. Do you want proof? Just take a look:
(27 April 2023: Erdoğan and
Putin celebrate cooperation
on Turkey's first nuclear power plant. – Euronews)
Nevertheless, despite all this,
Erdoğan has won the elections again.
Listen up.
(A POLITICAL EARTHQUAKE)
In February of this year, the Turkish city
of Gaziantep suffered a terrible earthquake,
which killed more than 55,000 people. The
lack of assistance and the government's
disastrous handling of the tragedy seemed
to open the door to political change.
(The economy is in ruins. AKP – Erdogan's
party – has depleted reserves and has vastly
expanded pledges and spending to bolster
its patronage network. I don't know how
the country can avoid economic collapse. –
Daron Acemoglu, economist and MIT professor)
What’s more, most of the opposition
united under a single candidacy:
Kemal Kılıçdaroğlu [keˈmal kutzdaɾolu], who
became the big favorite... And yet he lost.
He lost in the first and second rounds.
The Turks have bet on a political leader
who has shredded civil liberties, provoked
an economic crisis and who has clashed with
NATO and the European Union. And all
apparently for one very clear premise:
to make Turkey a great Islamic power.
Erdoğan has nurtured an unbridled nationalist
sentiment that has now given him victory.
We could say that he has become a kind of
Putin in Turkey. Once a moderate politician with
a zeal for renewing ties with the West, today he
has become almost, almost, a kind of nightmare.
An ally more uncomfortable than many enemies.
The question is:
How far do you think
Erdoğan will go? Will Turkey continue
to fall down the slippery slope of
autocracy? Will this country become
a kind of Russia in the Middle East?
Leave us your answer in the comments and
let's open a debate. And now, if you found
this video interesting, don't forget to give
it a like and subscribe to VisualPolitik if
you haven't already done so.
All the best and see you next time.